school district mariachi band gets a
major gig students will be actually
performing at the presidential
inauguration tomorrow
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how they're representing nevada
not only with music but culture
[Music]
las vegas high school are set to perform
on the national stage
never once did i think that we would be
able to have this opportunity to perform
for the president of the united states
angel miramontes and his classmates will
represent nevada in the virtual parade
across america
during the presidential inauguration an
unexpected honor for the senior who
plays violin in the group
we're going to be performing our own
tema our own team
and mariachi
[Music]
a video online teases the upcoming
appearance a pre-recorded virtual
production they record themselves
playing
we put all of the music together we send
them the final music and then they
record their video
[Music]
stephen blanco directs mariachi hoya he
says biden's team asked the group last
week to participate
it's not the first time though
performing for him the students played
for the president-elect when he visited
las vegas
last year i don't know of too many
things meaning more
principal ron gerzon says he is proud
but
he and blanco highlight the biggest
significance of this
celebrating different cultures
irrespective
of your background and your experience
you can be successful
my family is from mexico so it's a huge
thing for me
part of showcasing in america united
kristin drummond
8 news now the event will be live stream
starting at 12 15 tomorrow a link will
be on 8newsnow.com what a thrill for
those talented local kids